Oh George front of a line over a  defender and fancy door with the no-look  shot probably gonna make you high school  varsity team I'm just calming one kid in  the world who can do the tough stuff oh  oh no I'm out no let's go to prey on no  wait it's easy third cow  quit daydreaming kid you're not ready  for this court well I'll be ready I'm  gonna win this tourney and all y'all  older kids you won't even believe whoo  [Music]  hey man you're moving a car all by  yourself which you got cops yeah big  crane that live in this broken they  called me I'm boogie I'm Paul George you  ever think about playing basketball  don't play later oh and you can shoot  too  man there's a lot you don't know yeah oh  come on dog be careful let's run a break  your legs